from the very beginning of the program
we've we've been faced with the question
of how to define a successful society
but we also quickly agreed that we were
not going to try to come up with some
magic formula the argument we've
developed in our work is really a
complex argument in the sense that we
each look at different parts of the
animal so our response to us a
successful Society has both an
institutional part which you know what
does the state does redistribute
resources etc but it also has a cultural
part which is about recognition how do
the societies we live in give us tools
to build identities that are strong and
positive I would look at that in terms
of what type of society is going to help
people meet their needs and so what kind
of needs to people have people have a
need for safety and security we need
water we need food we need shelter we
need clothing social needs
right so relatedness and belonging a
sense of inclusion from my point of view
a successful society is one that
provides people with us certain level of
prosperity decent jobs at a living wage
for everyone society that distributes
the fruits of that growth relatively
equitably but also a society that is
tolerant where people are tolerant of
are those in other religious racial or
ethnic groups strong institutions are
primary social networks and the trust in
those institutions at the individual
level autonomy being able to learn and
to think critically being able to make
responsible decisions and
to enter live by them and to behave
accordingly I mean there are many
features of a successful society and I
think the important thing to realize is
that there are often trade-offs there
you can't always have all good things
all the time sometimes to have more of
one good thing you have to have a little
bit less of something else and so there
are trade-offs that's one of the great
things about human beings is we're
endlessly active and creative and and
we're never we're never satisfied with
we live in and and there will there will
always be people mobilizing to in in to
pursue a better vision of what what the
world looks like